we have a bravery deficit in the country
right now and we have a group of people
that are more than happy to take
advantage of that are you guys know this
guy Dave Rubin all right so here's the
deal Dave did our Philadelphia event and
tore the house down and so we were
chatting afterwards and he wanted to
come back and he wanted to do something
for his show the Reuben report which has
taken off and I said to him I said you
know look we'd love to do it we'd love
to get you talking about you know what
we're doing but I kind of had this
epiphany and I asked them backstage and
he's he's agreed which is awesome the
Dave is going through this
transformation of coming to the
principles of Liberty and so I would
like to interview Dave and really dig in
on how we got there and you've told me
backstage but I want to just get your
permission your OK for me to kind of dig
in and talk about this transformation
and talk about what got you from where
you were to be in here and I think we
can we can talk not just about that but
about you know what you're seeing and
what you're projecting out for the
future yeah well before we do anything
else so we are airing this not live
right now but this will be aired on my
channel so can you crazy libertarians
make some noise
[Applause]
all right
Wow
you know thing is if you go to a
progressive conference and you ask them
to make some noise there's like one guy
like can you can someone else clap for
me is that possible that one took a
second for you okay let's roll all right
so I want to go back you know you talk a
lot about kind of your experience
whether it's with the Young Turks or
maybe in the community in seen but do
you think there was one moment where you
realized I don't want to say that you
were wrong but you realized no no I was
wrong okay great yeah you realize you
know maybe I'm not seeing this correctly
or maybe there was something that
sparked you to kind of dig a little
deeper what was that was it a moment you
can point to was it a book was it a you
know somebody there was an influencer in
your life yeah you know there were a
couple things that happened over over
the course of a couple years that
started waking me up to some of this so
Bridgette fed Izzy who some of you guys
may know she's come up with a phrase
that I really like related to this that
most of us if you grow up in a Western
education system you sort of you have
factory settings that just start you off
like when you buy a computer with
factory settings or a television with
factory settings and those factory
settings because it's being handed down
from the education establishment the
political establishment the media
establishment they're all sort of
through the leftist prism you know like
we should give to these people and take
from these people there's a certain set
of ideas that we're all sort of supposed
to accept and I kind of accepted those
ideas and you know I've always
considered myself a liberal and I know
we're gonna talk about classical
liberalism obviously but I saw
progressives as kind of louder angrier
edgy or liberals and that kind of
appealed to me there was a sort of
over-the-top nature to it but it did
kind of appeal to me but after a year or
two of really being in on it and this is
when I was at the Young Turks there were
a bunch of things that that started
becoming really obvious and I think I'm
sure many of you have guys have gone
through this once you start seeing it
can't unsee it right I mean that's why
the plate the phrase the red pill really
resonates with people because for
example one of the things I really
started noticing just sort of at a broad
level was that everyone that
progressives disagreed with somehow was
a racist or a bigot or a homophobe or a
transphobic islamaphobe or we could go
on and on and I thought this this just
can't be right you know what I mean we
made maybe were right maybe us
progressives are right about things but
it can't possibly be that every single
person who disagrees with us is somehow
the worst of the worst and there were
many instances that I started really
seeing that the one that the one that
really cracked it for me which I'm sure
many of you have seen this this is about
five or six years ago Sam Harris was on
Real Time with Bill Maher and Bill Maher
of course is that really the standard
bearer for the left for liberals in the
United States and he had Ben Affleck on
and he was talking to Sam and Sam's a
neuroscientist and a well known atheist
they started talking about the
difference between Islam as a set of
ideas and Muslim Muslims as people you
would never want to be bigoted towards
people but you should be allowed to
criticize any set of ideas whether it's
a religious set of ideas or a political
set of ideas or anything else and an
Affleck who probably was on steroids
preparing for Batman basically told told
Bill Maher and Sam Harris that they were
gross and racist and the over-the-top
nature of it it somehow became very
obvious to me how poorly the left was
dealing with difficult I mean it's
really difficult stuff to talk about why
you should be able to criticize religion
without being bigoted towards people
that that's tough right and and and that
was just one of many things but that was
the one that I start it was the most
obvious example of something that I had
seen there was a seed that had started
to take root and he talked about kind of
the identity politics that we see from
the left I mean a lot of the folks in
this room you know the students when
we're working on campus you know if we
present a message of anything that is
not exactly in line with kind of these
big government solutions we do get
labeled yeah we get kind of grouped into
these you know whatever it is like you
said I'm a misogynistic racist
homophobic and it's it's I think cuz
we're not conforming do you think that
the left do you think that they lost
their mind at a certain point or do you
think it's just that certain people are
louder and that has become the tactic I
think there's a couple things happening
at once first off if you figure out a
trick that will silence your opponents
and it consistently works you're gonna
keep going back to it and that almost
explains why we're in the hysterical
place that we're at right now where you
can wear this this thing this sort of
hysteria around the left where they're
just attacking everybody and if Nancy
Pelosi says saying about AOC then AOC
says Nancy Pelosi is a racist because
it's a snake that eats its own tail but
there's a there's a reason for that
which is if you own the media if you
only establishment if you own the
parameters and the Overton Window that
the conversation is allowed to have
allowed to exist in well then when when
people start making some good points and
eventually those cries stop working
you've gotten fat on not working out not
working out your ideas so if you say I
mean this is I see this all the time
when I started sort of evolving on some
of the stuff I always tell people I
really believe the same things that I've
always believed I would say the one
place that I've really shifted is
economics where I certainly have shifted
more right and if you say to somebody
you know I'm for low taxes if you say to
a lefty I'm for low taxes you will often
find I'm sure you guys have had this
happen to you at college they will say
you're racist and you say well well what
what does that mean and they say well if
you're for low taxes that means you
don't want to help poor people and if
you don't want to help poor people that
somehow means you don't want to help
black people and if you don't want to
help black people you're racist and they
take you on this crazy adventure through
that now you can you can give them all
the the numbers right where the more we
pour money into these places and into
these districts you could look at all
the places where black unemployment the
highest and it's always Democrat run
cities and all of those things they're
not gonna really respond to that but
eventually I really believe this and I
think this is why probably people care
about my show eventually if you do your
best to just be a little bit better than
them
and calmly try to explain to them but
just because you feel something is right
it feels right to say Oh somebody's poor
I want to give them something and they
they never want to give it themselves
right they want they want somebody else
to give it but it feels Oh somebody's
poor I'm gonna give them something or or
any of these things it all feels right
and that's why Shapiro's line Bend
Shapiro's line but facts don't care
about your feelings that's why that
really took off because if you can sit
there with them long enough to get them
over their feelings and it ain't gonna
be easy and I guarantee you everyone in
this room has lost friends probably over
politics and probably not by your choice
it's pretty rare that I find a
conservative or a libertarian or a
classical liberal that just can't take
somebody on the left anymore it usually
is the other way because they will say
all those awful things about you but if
you're a little bit better than them and
it's gonna take practice and patience
then I think you can break through to
them and I that's what I've tried to do
with my show to varying degrees of
success I suppose yeah a million YouTube
subscribers is uh we're trying to reach
that yeah we'll get there someday so I
want to talk a little bit more about
kind of the the mob mentality because I
think that you've been kind of at the
forefront of trying to why shouldn't say
trying but having to cope with this you
know being somebody that has
transitioned you know from kind of I
mean the Young Turks to be more
classical liberal it's got to be
interesting for you to witness I would
say this you know canceled culture on
the airlines
you know we got a lot of fire this week
as we put out a piece in The Washington
Times about this whole Dave Chappelle
special and just you know how we
shouldn't it's it's a shame to see the
gut reaction from so many people that
are just commenting or even some
journalists that put out you know that
YouTube should pull this down there
Netflix should pull this down and do you
think it gets worse before it gets
better like do we hit it do we hit a
point where it's like you know something
I mean Chappelle talked about this where
something you tweeted when you were you
know 20 years old a lot of people in
this room are gonna be in that that age
bracket are we going to hit a spot where
people are numb to it and it's like
listen we all did that stuff or we and
and what we better get on that place
we better when do we get there the thing
is we have to get there if we don't get
to the place that we're all not trying
to cancel each other we will all cancel
each other we will end up in a in a
totalitarian state not necessarily
because of the government which I know
for most people in this room that's the
big fear it will be because we have
silenced ourselves I mean the amount of
people that I meet that are just good
decent people right like just decent
people that tell me all the time I'm
afraid to say what I think I'm afraid to
post that the people will tell me
they're afraid to post my videos and
I'll go think about this this is we're
not in Pakistan where if you're a
blogger you could be shot on the street
we're not there yet but we actually
could start veering there if every time
a good person like you guys if every
time you won't say what you think
especially when you're 18 19 years old
you guys will never have more passion
and and wherewithal and and lack of
world weariness to say what you think
then right now like it doesn't get
easier you know there's I think there's
this belief that for a lot of college
students that somehow like oh if I can
just suck it up now you know don't say
what I think now get the grade so I can
get into grad school get into grad
school so I can get the job if I can
just be quiet now I'll later on I'll
start saying what I think and it's like
that is the reverse of reality I don't
know if you guys know this but one day
you're gonna have to have a job and then
you're gonna have a house and a car and
a dog and a wife or a husband and kids
and something you gonna have all this
[ __ ] and you're gonna go now I'm gonna
start telling the world what I think
know it every day that you don't do it
is just is just chipping off your
ability to ultimately do it so you gotta
fight it and trust me they haven't
killed any of us yet I mean for those of
you that you know yet here in America I
mean really think of it I was sad that
you had to laugh at that but but but
think about that I mean for the for the
people that have been on my show that
you know that have survived the mob
Jordan Peterson survived the mob why did
the mob come after him because all he
said was I'm not against trans people
but I don't want the government to be
able to dictate my speech relative to
what pronouns I use when referring to
them he said I'll treat trans people
respectfully if they treat me
respectfully but the government can't
come and say that the mob went after him
tried to destroy him Bret wines
didn't want the school where he worked
Evergreen State to be segregated one day
a year based on the color of skin I'm
pretty sure Martin Luther King would
have been down with that the mob tried
to destroy him Brett didn't get
destroyed these guys are bigger now and
used their examples Lindsey Shepherd
from Wilfred Laurier who all she did was
show a video of Jordan Peterson in a
class as a TA and they tried to destroy
her they will keep doing it but if you
show a little bravery you you can spread
that bravery to you an untold amount of
people and we have a bravery deficit in
the country right now and we have a
group of people that are more than happy
to take advantage of that let me talk to
you about one of the things that you did
that I think was one of the most
courageous or fiscally irresponsible
decisions I've seen oh good god I've
made several of these so I don't know
where you're going so you know you
taking yourself off some of these
platforms you know whether it's patreon
YouTube I mean I want to talk a little
bit about just kind of big tech and
where you think the now I'm gonna say
where is it going but give me I mean
kind of your analysis for students what
what do you think has happened that has
forced these tech companies to get to a
point where I mean we're clearly seeing
some bias we're clearly seeing some
censorship and I want to ask this
question again I mean does it get better
or do we just see the marketplace work
where people actually leave some of
these mega tech corporations and I'm
also going to throw this in there a lot
of individuals and I will give you
credit for this have jumped to say the
government should be stepping in and
dictating how these companies can
operate now I don't take that stance I
haven't seen you take that stance I
appreciate that but I worry because I
mean you see people like Josh Hawley and
some of these other conservatives who
that's what they're trying to do they're
trying to most fight fire with fire and
get the government involved so think
about what an interesting situation we
have right now i I was right before I
went off the grid for the month for
August which I think we're gonna talk
about oh yeah I drew public pressure it
was the only way I could get a response
out of youtube I had to keep shaming
them on Twitter because they're one of
their Whistler whistleblowers that came
out that was an employee of Google
specifically said my name as one of the
people that they're censoring so I kept
going on Twitter and I kept tagging
Susan with Jeske who's the YouTube CEO
and finally she followed me and we had a
we had a video call a Skype call it was
off the record then I I was going up to
Silicon Valley so we had a meeting again
off the record and I won't repeat
anything that was said off the record
but I will say one thing that I I told
her at the end I said you know I'm
basically the last guy that's not
calling for government intervention
right now I mean think about this
Elizabeth Warren wants to break up big
tech and Tucker Carlson wants to break
up big tech they agree on basically
nothing now I obviously he's generally
speaking I agree far more with Tucker
Carlson than I do with Elizabeth Warren
and Tucker's a friend and a nice guy but
this is a really interesting spot if
you're if you're a liberty-loving person
if you're a limited government person
and yet you understand that we are in a
truly unique position right now this is
what is happening with big tech the
amount of information that Google
controls the amount they know about
every single thing that you do that
every single one of us has an iPhone or
something like it in our pocket the way
they can use the algorithms to make you
think a certain way the way that if you
start thinking one way they can actually
shift the way you think by suggesting
certain videos and not suggesting other
things the way they can shadow ban you
on Twitter and the way that you can
subscribe to videos and then not get
from a certain creator because that
doesn't fall in line what they like this
is a problem that is almost unthinkably
huge but is this the moment that we then
want to then give the power to the
government you're on Brooke from a are i
from iran institute who i'm sure many of
you guys know i did a panel with him
discussing this and he said the sort of
purist attitude on this which is well if
you don't have principles when they
matter then what's the point of having
them and i am trying my hardest as
someone that makes a living doing this
that is trying to communicate the ideas
that i believe in i am trying my hardest
not to be one of those people that at
the end is just gonna be like you know
what [ __ ] it regulate the hell out of
them i don't want that so you know i'm
working on some tech stuff myself which
we just announced
recently and my hope is that you know in
all movements whatever the weather there
are political movements or social
movements or whatever you know there a
lot of people do things differently MLK
did things a certain way and Malcolm X
did things a different way and you know
in comedy you know somebody like Chris
Rock is gonna is gonna curse a lot and
then you know I was gonna say Bill Cosby
but you know somebody like Bill Cosby
did some other [ __ ] but the point is
people are different that's what I'm
trying to say okay and and so my
position will be I am going to put as
much pressure as I can on them as a
public figure to change I'm gonna use
the market as I can I can use my voice
the tools that they give us and maybe
they'll boot me from these things and
we'll see but hopefully I just believe
that the free markets the way to do it
you know I live in California I pay my
state income tax on a California state
website it looks like prodigy from 1988
you know what I mean
so the idea that that the government's
gonna come in and a governor mean try to
imagine when they say break up big tech
what are you saying you have a
government regulator right like some
average Schmo that knows nothing about
nothing walk into Google and fix the
problem like it's it's actually crazy
but I did tell Susan I said I am the
last guy so so work with me here I don't
know that they're gonna work with me but
we'll see but this is I think this is
really the issue of our time because if
you guys can't communicate with each
other if you are afraid that the
platforms that you're on are gonna come
get you
coupled with the political madness that
were in man week what a toxic still we
have so we have to start fixing this you
know one of the things that we really
try to teach is this idea of effectively
using your time and I think the role of
social media you know when it comes to
when we're trying to advance ideas you
know the joke at young Americans for
liberty is don't waste your time getting
in their social media arguments you know
we see these trolls and different people
are coming after you all the time but
what's interesting to me is you know you
take a month-long hiatus this is your
third year doing your duty so I think
you guys all find this fascinating a
month totally unplugged no cell phone no
Internet no newspaper not getting any
updates why do you do it and I'm very
jealous that you do this you know what
would have kind of been the outcomes of
it what does it produce does it get you
you know do you get to see an outsider's
view because I think that sometimes we
don't we don't realize how much does
control us and I don't mean that now you
know a biased way somebody's you know
pulling the strings I mean I think that
we are we look at our phone constantly
you know we're we're not even realize
we're scrolling on Facebook sometimes
and 30 days or 33 days you know
month-long hiatus
it does sound pretty refreshing yeah
well I mean think about it this way
you know I'm not that much older than
you guys I'm 43 which I guess feels kind
of older right but it's not I'm not that
old
right and I remember when I was a junior
in college was the first time that our
sophomore in college I think I was the
first time that I saw a visual Internet
I remember before that we had an email
address but I don't even know what you
could do with it or who you would
message or why you would do it didn't
even have your name it was just like a
crazy series of characters but I
remember I was a sophomore in college
and a guy down the hall started
screaming that he was on the world wide
web and a bunch of us like ran into his
room and there was his little little
screen you know a little you know our
old home old man
and it was just in color it was
incredible and and it had a Yankees logo
and a Royals logo and it said Yankees
three Royals one and I swear to God I
remember saying this is the stupidest
thing I have ever seen
I kid you not I remember saying that
because it was like well why wouldn't I
have just got the score at on
SportsCenter you know an hour later or
something like that
things have changed so fast right now
and the amount of information were being
constantly slammed with at that any
morning you can wake up and decide to
try to destroy the life of another human
you've never heard of who lives halfway
across the world or they might try to do
that to you and then all the good stuff
to all the incredible stuff right like
I'm a product of the internet I think
that the the conversations that I've had
on the show have made have helped stem
the tide of some of this stuff and in
some ways turn the tide but I had I
think we have no idea how the Internet
is actually changing us that all of us
are walking around with the device in
our pocket that connects us to the rest
of the world we know revolutions have
started because of this just look at
Egypt Tahrir Square a couple of years
ago look what's happening in Hong Kong
right now but what I felt was because of
the the craziness of social media and
that you know on any given morning I can
if my phone I try not to bring my phone
in my bedroom anymore but you know if I
just took my phone off my nightstand and
I looked at Twitter the first thing I
could see is that a pink anime Fox is
telling me that I'm an [ __ ] that's
not like like that's not a great way to
start the day you know what I mean and
yet we we all do it we look at our
phones in bed people are talking to us
to our face and our reaction time is
slower we don't know what it's doing to
our memory we don't know what it's doing
to our ability to be social to our
ability to look at other people as human
beings to actually look someone in the
eye when you're talking to them I mean
it all of these things I think are
rapidly changing so I did it three years
ago sort of just as a test just could I
do it and then I really I loved it I
mean I felt calmer and more patient and
you know we still put videos up because
you know if you disappear from the
internet for a month everyone thinks
you're gone altogether but it's getting
harder and harder to do because I have a
bigger business now we have more
employees I mean it's a great set of
problems that I have I mean literally
this last time your book came out what
like three days before yeah my book came
out three days before we hit number
three on Amazon just on on pre-sales
nine months before the book came out you
know we just hired a whole bunch more
people I just announced
couple days ago we're doing this deal
with the blaze and and I have so much
going on which is all great like it's
all great but in a way that made it
clearer to me that I had to take some
time off I mean just think about it for
you guys like you guys are in college
like when's the last time you just took
a day off just a day once a week you
know I when I tweet about sometimes
taking weekends off Ben Shapiro I'll be
like yeah the Jews have been doing it
for about 4000 years and it's like you
know one day a week right the Sabbath
and you doesn't matter what religion but
you know whatever the holy day might be
but there's some value in stepping away
from some of that because it's it's
crazy I know most people can't do that
amount of time and it was weird man and
you know the other thing was fun was
that people were keeping me honest
because wherever I went people would
come up to me and say you really up you
know I'm at Whole Foods and people would
say you're not really off the grid come
on you got a phone in your pocket and I
literally would have to take my stuff
out of my pockets and show people I have
no phone no nothing I didn't know
anything about the news I mean it really
I didn't you know that that T word that
everyone says all the time the Trump
have you heard about this guy I did not
hear anything about Trump basically for
for 33 days love him or hate him it
doesn't matter it was just like it was
just nice to just escape the madness a
little bit yeah you know I I want to get
into some of the issues because I think
your perspective of coming from the left
I think you I get very frustrated when
the left is hypocritical on some issues
because there's people who believe in
civil liberties individual liberty peace
you know some of these things that we
see hey let's just be consistent on it
you know when you went from Obama well
from one from Bush to Obama saw a lot of
Republicans who you know either didn't
say any under Bush or they changed their
tune under Obama and you see the same
thing you know as the president switches
parties but like war is the issue that
just rubs me it just I don't understand
how somebody can claim to be anti-war
understand putting the troops first this
idea that we shouldn't be
nation-building having troops in 120
countries you stand up against it then
Obama gets elected all of a sudden the
anti-war left disappears
I'm actually surprised that they haven't
come back I'm surprised I mean I haven't
seen them or heard them especially not
that level do you think the anti-war
left is going to come back is that issue
going for them you know is his trunk
with this America first foreign policy
you can think whatever you want about
the actions his rhetoric I would argue
he's been one of the most peaceful with
his rhetoric presidents probably last 30
or 40 years well I'm not hearing that
obviously from the left yeah well it
goes to there's there's so much there
right so one of the things right right
before the election when when so say the
six months before the 2016 election when
Trump was really gaining steam and
suddenly you know Trump said not see all
his supporters are all right and racists
and all of this stuff I I did many
videos on how this is a huge it's just a
tactical mistake if nothing else by the
left you cannot label all your
supporters and you can't say Trump's
Hitler because what might happen and I
think this is what has happened is if
you keep saying this guy's Hitler
well you're painting yourself into a
niche intellectual corner because what
it what happens if he turns out not to
be Hitler and let's say you know he
lowered some taxes let's say the economy
is doing well let's say he doesn't try
to nation-build and get us into all of
these wars
well you can't turn around and be like
oh you know that Hitler guy's not that
bad right so you're really right like
you really have put you box yourself in
it's not what you've done to him it's
what you've done to yourself
and I think that's partly why there's
such chaos right now because the the
economy's doing well we're not going to
war one of the things I just found out
because I was gone
was that he's now trying to put an end
to the Afghanistan war which people
don't realize it but it is the longest
war in American history nobody even
knows why we're there anymore like let's
leave and and most
what was that Oh bring them home I
thought it was build the wall I was like
all right all right libertarians are
always keeping me on my toes now just
for the record bring them home were the
three work okay just to be very clear
yeah it was bringing them home yes but
but two specifically your question about
the anti-war left I mean think about
this so Tulsi Gabbard who is by far yeah
well I'm glad you're applauding her
because she was literally DMing me as I
was backstage and I think we have her on
on Sunday it's gonna be our first walk
and live stream ever now it better
happen now that I announced it but but
think about this Tulsi Gabbard who is
who she served in the American military
right she just went back I think to do a
little you know some of the extra duty
she's absolutely anti-war clearly but
you know if there's a neocon here she's
the one eighty of that
well what happened the more that she
started to gain traction suddenly all of
these hit pieces were coming out in
BuzzFeed and HuffPo and Vox and all the
all the usual journalistic places and I
used quotes around that obviously that
she was she's conservative and she's
liked by the right and I thought this is
really bizarre so you're telling me now
that anti-war is a conservative position
so I I don't know what has happened I
mean I think the DNC is such a corrupt
twisted organization and it's so clear
look they screwed Bernie over last time
they're screwing over Andrew yang now
and they'll figure out a way to screw
over whoever they have to to get
whatever it is they want I'm actually
not even sure what they want anymore
because Biden's head is probably going
to explode before the election so and
Biden by far by far in my opinion the
best one of them I mean that's just a
said you know I feel I actually feel bad
for the guy I didn't even mean to be so
glib when I said that like he's clearly
having some some you know health issues
and I think there's some cognitive stuff
happening and I don't even think he
wanted to run but yeah they're the
Democrats for as crazy as things are for
the Republicans because you know there's
there's trumpism and then there's you
know pretty much everything else and how
do those things work together for as
crazy as that may feel what's happening
to the Democrat
because of the the the lunacy that the
progressives have just spread everywhere
is immeasurably worse I think let me put
you on the spot who do you think if you
had to bet today who do you think wins
it wins from the the Democrats are just
a legend my guess I mean it's such a
depressing group of people at it's like
it really is it's like every time I've
watched the debate or I listened to any
of them talk it's like why would I want
you involved in my life like go away go
somewhere else and bother other people
like you should and that by the way
that's that's another reason that you
can you can really unfurl the lunacy of
leftism really easily because you know
if they had a consistent set of views so
you can say what you want about the
right but the right basically and
certainly in this room what is the right
care about the individual that if that
every single one of us should have
individual rights that are exactly the
same regardless of the color of your
skin or your gender or any of those
things I can't look at any I mean think
how depressingly twisted it would be if
I looked at any of you and I was like oh
she's black so she must think this or or
he's gay so he must think this or
something like that but yet that is what
the left is doing and that's that's so
ironic right now because if if you
really believe as so many of the
progressives do that that Trump is
Hitler and evil and all of those things
well the answer isn't it's just to get
our guy to be in that position of power
the answer is let's take the power away
from that office which is how it was
supposed to be set up in the first part
[Applause]
so if you were a betting man you'd put
your mom oh so I didn't answer the
question how about that I'm trying to
vote for you guys you just talk long
enough so that they forget what the
question was Obama used to do that all
the time do you remember the Obama press
conference is that when they would be
like mr. president you know what's the
temperature outside like six hours later
like it was okay if I was a betting
person I think it's probably gonna be
Elizabeth Warren I almost see sort of no
yeah but but I could say anything you'd
boo any of them might be there they're
all terrible they're horrible
I mean even did you watch this climate
change summit the amount of lunacy
Birdie was literally demanding that we
offer free abortions to people in South
America to stop climate change I mean
that's how I'm not making that up I am
NOT making that up we used to there used
to be some American program where we
would offer abortion services in other
countries which what does that have to
do with shouldn't we be doing things in
our country or forget abortion
specifically but he literally was
bringing that up that if we don't
reenact this policy that that you know
populate I mean he wants these dados
basically I would vote for tan O's
before I would vote for any of these
people but so I think I think I think
Elizabeth Warren probably I think the
most beautiful part of watching it all
unfold will be the way that they have to
destroy Bernie because Bernie he has to
be destroyed he's an old white man at
the end and at the end that is that is
how they will judge him and they will
take him out because that's how the game
is played and if you remember in the
last go-around with this remember that
moment where Bernie was on stage and the
black lives matter activists grabbed the
mic out of his hand and he just moved
over and stood there like a little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh I'm okay on the language right we're
good yeah but but there's a reason he
did it he it wasn't because it was what
he believed he should do it was because
by the intersectional game that the
progressives have created he knew if he
grabbed the mic back at his own event
from black lives matter activists they
were gonna say he was racist and destroy
him so they are just buying their time
to take out Bernie at some point and
Elizabeth Warren will have to do it and
then I think it sets up you know then
then there's a woman running against
Trump I mean it just gets this all to
the the zenith of of lunacy let me ask
you about one of the things that kind of
I always see as a debate or a discussion
is the idea of educating or maybe
focusing more on some of the cultural
things versus the political arena I
think you coming through you know the
comedian side - Young Turks and
obviously those transformation and
having your own platform being a
personality do you think that you have
changed your mind on this do you think
that there is one because because my
take has always been that there's got to
be a balance right I think if you have a
core set of principles you know you go
out you engage folks you figure out ways
to connect with them whether it's
through culture whether it's through
education but then the political arena
has just been beating the [ __ ] out of us
for the past 30 years so you can't
ignore that side do you agree with kind
of that take that there's a hybrid or do
you think we need to be a you know we're
failing in one section and we're gaining
in another what's kind of yours well as
I referenced earlier with MLK and
Malcolm X whatever whatever the movement
is whatever you care about is there's
many ways to skin a cat right and I
think you need people that can purely
deal with things at the idea level right
that can really lay out simple
principles so I try when I have somebody
like let's say Jordan Peterson on who's
talking about Nietzsche and Dostoevsky
and some seriously high-level stuff I
think one of the things I'm good at is
distilling some of that so that the
average person who maybe can't read all
of these things or take all of this in
can can digest it and hopefully find a
path where they can you know find out
more if that's what they want to do and
I think in in this
political atmosphere that we need we
need people to understand I think the
the basics of the founding of the
country of the principles of
individualism understand why the
Constitution was written why they write
it the way that they did what does the
Bill of Rights actually mean all of
these things you know understand why why
did they write regardless of your
feelings about religion why did they say
these were god-given rights and that it
wasn't the government that was giving
you those rights these are deeply
important things to understand but if
you're only gonna talk about that you're
not gonna get these guys and what what
does get these guys is comedy is memes
is all of is is shitposting I mean it's
all of those things so you need you need
some version of all of that and everyone
plays a little bit of a different role
in that so I think the important thing
in this is what I would say about about
anything you should do what you think
you should do and and if you do that and
you're an idea guy and you do it well
you'll feck people and if you do that
and you're funny
you'll affect people in it and whatever
that means to you you got to hit it on
many fronts but this is where you know I
mean I always tell you it's like I love
coming to these yeah things because for
whatever little differences we have it's
utter I know none of you actually that
would never that would never cause an
irreparable problem for us like I know
you guys want to work through issues if
I had a difference of opinion we could
you know have a drink after talk it out
I mean we have some difference of
opinion and we can we can battle that
through and that's what I meant before
about just being a little bit better
than the other guys because they're
pretty hysterical right now and if we
just show oh you know what somebody's a
little more conservative on say abortion
than I am and I'm a little more hardcore
on low taxes or states rights than they
are but we basically want to live in the
same country well now we can start
expanding the tent and the progressives
are just purging people right that's
what they're doing they're taking good
decent liberals like me like Brent
Weinstein who I talked about before
or his brother Eric Weinstein plenty I
mean there's a zillion people Sam Harris
a million people there actually it's
many millions of decent liberals because
decent liberals do exist but they've
been cowered into silence so why not as
the progressives are purging all of
their free thinker
and it's not even that they're purely
freethinkers they're just somebody that
might have one random other thought
while while they're purging them why not
have the people especially on the
Liberty side of things really show yeah
I'm willing to agree to disagree and I
want to live in a country where my
neighbor can think something different
that sounds pretty great to me
[Applause]
so I want to talk about Jordan Peterson
yes so letting you know you know Dave
toured with Jordan talking to I mean
thousands thousands of people and what
fascinates me about Jordan Peterson I
cannot stop watching the interview he
did the one that you know kind of went
off where I felt like every single time
he would say anything what's her name
Kathy Kathy Newman
yeah Kathy Newman would say what you're
saying what you're saying is and she'd
fill in the blank and to hear Jordan who
at the time when I first watched this I
didn't know who he was I didn't know any
of his beliefs but to hear him say no no
I'm not saying that at all right and
that was a pretty decent Peterson you
see how the boys kind of Fraga fide
there that was good
but when he when he would say that it
resonated with so much of not just what
I've been through but with so many of
our student activists when it's like you
know anything you say is just
immediately paraphrased into this
horrific you know it just it's just
factually not correct so I guess my
question I have a few questions about
Peterson but I want to kind of open it
up to why do you think people reacted
the way they did let's let's not even
say I mean when the mob went after him
but just I mean it wasn't like they went
after I mean he just took off and with
you being on the road with them and you
kind of understanding him at a much
deeper level you know what what do you
think really sparked kind of this
Peterson mania of you know yeah I agree
with this guy and he's just saying
things I'm not used to hearing yeah well
I think you hit the nail on the head
related to the Kathy Newman thing
because so many of us we're dealing with
that all the time that you're just
trying to lay out a simple perhaps hard
truth and what you get in exchange is
you know so what you're saying is or
you're a bigot or a racist the rest of
it and there's a beautiful moment in
that where he says something to the
effect of well you don't
and offending me that wasn't so good all
right you know but his because he
basically was saying well you might be a
saying to him you might be offending
trans people or whatever and and his
point was well you don't mind offending
me and but she had as a lefty she has
this hierarchical category of who can be
offended and all that I think that
moment took off because of that because
it was just a simple example of keeping
your cool knowing what you're saying and
then really the moment where Kathy kind
of couldn't speak because you could see
the conflicting ideas that just sat in
her head all sort of colliding into each
other so she really couldn't get out of
it and and you know the funny part is
that right after that I wonder how many
of you guys know this within hours after
the clip started going viral she was
taking selfies and and doing a video I
think in her car with the coworker
talking about all the trolls that were
coming after her but then once it really
caught on next thing you know she
started playing the victim and now you
know all she's getting death threats and
all these things and it's all not true
but she then realized the power of
playing the victim and all that instead
of actually going into a conversation
and knowing what you're talking about
enough to be able to have that back and
forth just broadly on Jordan the best
thing that I can say about Jordan so we
did about a hundred and ten stops in a
year it was incredible we went to dozens
of countries truly the best thing that I
can say about Jordan is he is the real
deal
I have never met someone in this space
that the exact man that you guys know
that you watch these videos of is the
exact guy the second the cameras go off
I never saw him be rude to anyone
anywhere I mean try to imagine the
amount of people that would come up to
us everywhere airports bathrooms
restaurants all the time it's a minute
before a show he's running late stop ask
them how they're doing what you know
what their name is and and the other
thing and this is probably more
important I never saw him break one of
the twelve rules
he had many opportunities that he could
have lied to somebody about he oh I
can't talk I gotta go or whatever he
never broke one of the twelve rules as a
matter of fact there was one night some
of you guys may have seen the picture we
were in London
Jordan and I and Maajid Nawaz you
probably know had dinner at Douglass's
ma Douglas Murray's flat that's that's
apartment in London EADS and we had
dinner there and you know one of the
rules is at the 12th room I mean maybe
the 11th rule about petting a cat if you
see one on the street and it really what
he's saying there is you know don't
forget to stop and smell the roses so
Douglas had a cat and we're in there for
about three hours we're eating we're
drinking we're having a great time and I
noticed about three four hours in and I
had a plenty of drinks I was like I
don't think Jordan has pet this cat and
I was like if he doesn't pet this cat
the guy's a fraud like and I couldn't
and then you know like then and then
were like five hours in I'm really drunk
and I'm like I got a pet I couldn't stop
thinking about it like if he doesn't pet
this cat like I'm on tour with the
biggest fraud in the history of the
world anyway we're saying our goodbyes
Jordan gets on the ground that Jordans
really tall and like he gets on the
ground and sits with the cat basically
sitting in the cat's bed you know just
like little flatbed and just try I mean
you can picture it because you can sort
of picture Jordans hands and just
petting petting petting the cat and I
thought all right the gig goes on we're
gonna be okay yeah he said he's a great
guy and he's the real deal and and and
he's serious about his ideas and and and
I'm a better person for having done the
tour truly yeah good for you yeah the
thing that fascinates me I see this a
lot when people have opinions it's very
easy to what I should say it's difficult
to state an opinion that you know is
gonna be against the grain yeah and you
know that I wouldn't say it's
controversial but you know is you know
the person saying it feels it or knows
it as fact believes it as fact and then
they kind of stop and I think that's
just one of the note I want to make in
that interview where it's like you know
he would say something and stop and it's
just so not accepted in society to say
some of the things he would say without
like but you know this this and this or
you know I believe this that's an
opinion I mean he just would say it well
the irony of course was that every time
the media would try to sandbag him and
try to destroy him which we saw many
times you guys may remember that
one of the biggest moments was when the
New York Times wrote that piece that
Jordan is for enforced monogamy remember
that and everyone made it sound like he
wants to basically put make women slaves
and we're gonna be in the hands made
tail enforcement ugly just means
marriage it's but if you look actually
Eric Weinstein checked and on the New
York Times archives the only other two
references to enforce monogamy are
positive references about marriage that
marriage is a fundamental building block
for a Western society it's it causes us
to reproduce and have familial bonds and
all of these things but the more they
attacked him by him just keeping his
cool and this is this is a good lesson
for any of you guys if you're ever gonna
be brave enough to say anything you
believe in the more they attacked him
the more he stood his ground and he
would say he would say you know by
nature I'm not a combative person and
that's hard to believe when you see
these people they're in these fights
constantly but he would stand his ground
say what he believes and say simple
truths
I'm not against trans people but the
government can't tell me what to call
somebody I'm for marriage I mean you
know basic stuff and if you do that and
you don't lose your cool well everyone
he's a worldwide phenomenon and those
things go hand in hand
yeah so I want to go back to you know we
talked free speech kind of as a broad
intent but I want to talk you know
specifically a lot of the students in
the room and kind of this campus culture
of free speech you know you see a lot of
comedians that won't go to campus just
because of some of the backlash and the
current environment that's been created
so one of the things that I really think
is missing amongst the libertarian and
conservative crowd is this idea that we
continue to say campuses biased campus
shuts down our speakers they don't
recognize our student organizations they
don't let us get rooms you know to
actually have have speakers or meetings
but then we don't do anything about it
and about three almost four years ago
now you know we launched a program
called the national fight for free
speech campaign with the idea of saying
let's stop just complaining let's figure
out what are these bureaucrats and the
college administrators doing to shut
down our groups or to shut down speakers
and you know you have certain campuses
need to get a permission slip to go out
and do activism and talk to people a lot
of them will charge the outrageous
security fees that's weaker at the
campus and I love how you say that it's
the new one because what happens is and
these are typically you know liberal
campus bureaucrats somebody tries a new
coat or a new policy and it works and
then all of a sudden you see other
people picking it up well we used to
when we're trying to combat them we will
try to purposefully do an event that is
against the code so let's say they have
these free speech zones right they say
okay listen it's a public school we're
supposed to uphold the First Amendment
but just to protect everyone we have a
small zone it's the size of let's say an
iPhone on a tennis court right if that's
the campus and this is where you're able
to speak freely well we will
purposefully do an event outside of it
and it's funny we used to do a free
speech wall the university said it's a
fire hazard right I mean they they're
very smart
nicely smart these administrators so
then we to push back now we do free
speech beach balls these giant beach
balls are roll around campus but we do
these events but it's crazy to me that
college administrators will shut down
not controversial opinion I mean they do
that and I don't I don't believe they
should be doing that but we have
students who have handed out pocket
constitutions they've gotten arrested
and put in jail the document literally
has the First Amendment written in it so
what do you think is what do you think
has caused this authoritarian belief and
and do you really think it's that
administrators want to protect students
now is it more of a control thing nope
it's it's neither it's actually it goes
back to the core of what I talked about
are the factory settings before and it
goes back to what has happened with the
modern left that has that in academia
more than anywhere else I mean this is
where this whole horrible set of ideas
of post-modernism took root and all of
these people know the administrators and
the faculty know if they'd except with a
few exceptions University of Chicago is
pretty good on it and there's a couple
other schools that are that are fighting
for free speech but they
no as an administrator that if they dare
stand up and defend been Shapiro's
ability to come to a school or the I
mean look the idea that Shapiro whatever
you guys disagree with him about is fine
the idea that he's a controversial
speaker is completely bananas Shapiro
probably I would guess agrees with you
know policies of Ronald Reagan probably
99% now you may not like some of those
policies that's fine but the point is
that it was mainstream conservative
thought only you know 2530 years ago
something like that but they know that
if they dare step up and fight the
monster well the monster will come for
them so that also goes back to why I
know that a Bernie will eventually be
eaten by this thing it it's a constant
movement of destruction it's not about
creation there was a video I'm sure some
of you guys saw this I spoke at the
University of New Hampshire it has a
couple million views and before the
event right before the end about an hour
before they said we can't secure a room
on campus
apparently I'm so controversial that
they could not secure a room now so they
had to take it off site so we had a
condo maybe four hundred students there
so and and it was sold out for the size
of that room we had it was four hundred
people in a 400 person room there were
more people that wanted to get in they
couldn't get in but then they said we
can't secure the room so they moved us
to the local hockey rink which sat ten
thousand people so I spoke for four
hundred people in a ten thousand seat
arena which is extremely bizarre but I
don't bring that up because I'm talking
about the numbers as much as they
already said we lost if a university
says we cannot even secure our own
campus they have already lost and then
you know the protesters come in and you
know they they scream that I'm not for
free speech or I'm a bigot and uh not
seeing the rest of it one of the girls
kept calling me a homophobe which my
husband has no idea
you know it's like and you know the best
part of that one and if you haven't seen
this it's on YouTube just search Dave
Rubin New Hampshire something there's
there was a woman in the back screaming
at me that I hate trans people she kept
saying I hate trans people so I said I
just want to be very clear about my
feelings towards trans people I want
them to be treated with the exact same
dignity and respect and the exact same
laws that under the same laws that
everyone else has to be I said
specifically to her I made sure to look
at her I said I hope that you have
someone that you love in your life and
you found happiness and all of these
things and then she called me Hitler in
a Nazi and all that bla bla bla but the
best part of this I did not know this
until weeks later it turns out that she
was a gender studies professor at the
University I mean really when you think
about how deeply corrupt so you abut you
have a faculty member of a really made
up you know it's not it's not a it's not
a real set of ideas right it's not but
it could have just it could have just as
easily been an economics professor or
whatever else the idea that they are
literally they're shouting down speakers
and you know I'm not I don't want you
guys to mob her anyone else watching
this tomorrow it doesn't even matter it
would be nice I suppose if the students
of the school did something but that she
felt empowered enough because of her
place in the intersectional scale that
she knew she could go to an event
screamed down to a speaker try to
silence a speaker and know that she'd
have complete impunity and no matter
what I said I mean that's the other
thing
I offered her every piece of goodness
that I had to say I don't know what our
differences are exactly but I certainly
don't hate you and I don't I don't hate
I certainly don't hate anyone because of
their identity but but that's the weird
state that they were in and and I
suppose that it'll probably keep getting
worse because I don't know if you know
this but we're in an election year and
we hey we ain't seen nothing yet right
so you've had a tremendous journey to
get to where you are where are you
heading next I mean do you see yourself
cranking out a lot more content when it
comes to the Rubin report do you see
yourself you know only doing it for a
couple more
going to do something I mean what's
what's next for you well I'm pretty sure
well I mean there's a couple things so I
actually don't think I should be doing
more content because I think there's
enough out there you know like I want
people to still get laid
does anyone here get laid one guy okay
very good
I you know my belief is you know look I
love this stuff I love this I love
talking about ideas I love being in
front of crowds I like engaging within
people people about ideas but my feeling
is that if I do you know a couple shows
per week we usually do about two
hour-long interview spur week I assume
that if you listen to one of my shows
you probably maybe listen to a little
bit of Sam Harris a little bit of rogue
in a little bit of Shapiro Peterson ba
ba if you give five or ten out of your
hours a week to some of this stuff like
that's great and and I don't think we
need that much more the people that are
glued to this all the time I actually
think that's starting to become a
problem because there's a whole other
world out there you should know about
these the issues that I think we've been
talking about up here because they're
important but but you shouldn't let it
completely take over your life I think
in a weird way that's what's happened
with the left because they they believe
that politics is everything they think
that they can fix everything through
politics and ironically I think most
people in this room and certainly I I i
believe that politics is the problem you
know I mean that's the that's the
inherent problem that we have I would
rather get to a place where the
government small enough that it can't
affect us that much so I that's the idea
that I want to push out there more than
anything else so we'll keep doing this
we just signed this great distribution
deal with the blaze we I've got my book
coming out and we we just announced so I
because I didn't want to have the
government regulate YouTube I started a
tech company and we've built a really
awesome app for creators that will help
them write their own terms of service
and natively upload video and
communicate with their audience we're
going into beta testing next week so
we're gonna build I thought I can't
solve the problem for everybody but I
can thank you sir
so so what we did was we rebuilt an app
that basically we're starting with my
community and we're gonna secure my
community and it'll be if you're a
member of the Reuben Report app you'll
be able to communicate with each other
you'll be able to communicate with me I
can livestream in there you know we've
got different payment processors all of
those things as I said native upload
video so we're not dependent on YouTube
it doesn't solve all of the problems but
then we can give that app to all sorts
of other creators whether it's political
people or whatever I'll unboxers I don't
know what people are doing on YouTube
whatever the hell they're doing on there
but anyone can be partisan if you want
to secure your community and have it
Terms of Service that works for your
community and guess what you're also
going to kill 99% of the relentless
awful trolls because trolls don't pay
yet a troll eeeh so web even if you
charge a twenty five cents a month
you'll eliminate most of that and then
if they want to pay you to do it you
either suck it up and it just increases
your your monthly income or you just say
alright you're gone you're out of here I
don't want your money and then you're
not infringing on anyone's free speech
because it's not a platform my feeling
is that the day of the platforms is over
the Internet
had a great run for twenty years and I
think we're starting to watch it implode
right now it's kind of eating itself the
way everything is on Twitter where they
cannot you know how can you you can have
we're gonna ban Alex Jones but you can
have Hamas we're gonna take Louis
Farrakhan's to blue check away but you
can have this like none of it makes any
sense they don't even want it to make
sense because they just want to keep us
in constant chaos so my feeling was if I
could solve my problem
that would be the beginning and that's
that's what we're doing oh but as far as
how long I'll do all this I don't know I
truly don't know I mean after 33 days
away there was something nice about not
being in the fray as much as I love this
but you know we've got real problems and
I think I've offered a little bit of a
chance to to solve some of those
problems so I'm not going anywhere yet
how about that like that so I want to
end
oh I will say this though when I go it's
gonna be one tweet who is John Galt and
then I am gone like I will this up here
so we've got four hundred students here
we're Alcon Austin and you know I've
appreciated you let me flip the script
and interview you what's one piece of
advice maybe a lesson or something for
all these folks in this room that want
to get these ideas they want them to go
mainstream I think earlier your your
quip about you know there you got to
focus on what you're good at that's
great
is there something you would say is kind
of a send off to get them and I want to
say motivated but just something you
could show don't be afraid to be proud
of the fact that we truly live in the
greatest country in the history of the
United States this you say history of
the United stocks and the history of the
United States Jesus I've been traveling
a lot of people I just got back on the
grid in the in the history of the world
in the history of the world
to be clear I am talking about the
United States this is the greatest
country that the world has ever seen
more people from more corners of the
earth literally every place on earth
have come to America still want to come
to America nobody leaves nobody leaves
Lena Dunham is still here you know Debra
Messing ain't going anywhere
they never leave everyone wants to come
here right we don't stop people from
leaving so the same people that you know
it's like the left will scream about
open borders and then also tell you what
an evil horrible place it is so it's
like you want everyone to just share in
the HAR what do we what are we really
talking about here but but the point is
that understand that the only privilege
that you have in this room is that
you're privileged to live in the United
States that is the truth think about
your grandparents everyone in this room
for one second think about your
grandparents I guarantee you I guarantee
you for 99.9% of the people in this room
your life is better than your
grandparents life and that is what the
United States has afforded everyone
regardless of race or religion or creed
or any of that nonsense nobody cares
about that stuff we have been tricked
into thinking that everyone is walking
around with these evil racist xenophobic
views it is simply not the case most
people don't care about it it is being
mainstreamed by the group of people who
do care about it and ironically that's
the people that call you bigots but you
are not bigots and fight to keep this
thing going you know there Louis you
always see this thing in the media how
don't we then the United States under
Trump nobody respects the United States
anymore and nobody respects the United
States I did I did you know fifteen
European countries with Jordan in every
stop that we did now I get it it's a bit
of a select audience at our shows but in
every stop that we went to people still
wanted the United States to be that
shining beacon they'd be our first
amendment but they think it is the
greatest thing ever so don't give it up
because by the way it's getting pushed
towards the paper shredder
don't you know keep fighting for these
things and because if you don't don't
well clearly there's more than anything
else don't think anyone else is gonna do
it for you that really isn't a simple
way to say it no one else is gonna do it
for you so do it do it yourself
and you'll feel better you will feel
better and more accomplished and more
honest and decent
really ladies and gentlemen big round of
applause mr. Dave Rubin if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell